[ LAUGHTER ]
[ Laughter ]
>> Sorry, I couldn't>> SORRY, I
COULDN'T SEE MY
seeNOTES. my
notes
.GOOD EVENING.
Good evening.
I'm Susan VidaI'M SUSAN VIDA,
AND I AM SO
, and I am soLUCKY TO BE THE
CHIEF OF THE
luck
lucky to be the chiefMUSIC
DIVISION HERE AT THE
of the
musicLIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
division here at the
Library of Congress.
ItIT IS MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
is my pleasure to welcome
membersMEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND
THEIR
of Congress and their
staff, otherSTAFF, OTHER FRIENDS
IN OUR LIVE
friends in our live
audienceAUDIENCE HERE ON CAPITOL
HILL,
here on Capitol Hill,AND THOSE
OF YOU WATCHING
and those of you watching
remotelyREMOTELY FROM ALL OVER
THE
WORLD.
from all overHELLO, BRAZIL.
the world
world.
Hello, Brazil.
Hello, IHELLO, ITALIA.talia.
A COMPLETELY FREE CONCERT SERIES
OF WHICH WE ARE EXTREMELY PROUD.
OVER THE YEARS, MANY LEGENDARY
FIGURES WHO HAVE SHAPED OUR
SOUND WORLD AND CHANGED OUR
LIVES HAVE APPEARED ON THIS
STAGE.
TO MENTION JUST A VERY FEW,
JELLY ROLL MORTON, AARON
COPELAND, LEONARD BERNSTEIN.
LEONTINE PRICE, PAUL
McCARTNEY, DIONNE WARWICK.
AUDRA McDONALD, ESPERANZO
SPALDING, AND THOUSANDS MORE.
AS YOU CAN TELL, I'M VERY PROUD
OF OUR TRACK RECORD IN
PRESENTING ARTISTS WHO ARE TRULY
AMAZING MUSICAL TALENTS,
CREATORS WITH A HUGE IMPACT ON
OUR CULTURE AND SOCIETY.
TONIGHT IS THE OPENING EVENT FOR
THE WEEK IN WHICH WE CELEBRATE
THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF EMILIO
AND GLORIA ESTEFAN.
THE LIBRARY IS HONORING THEM
WITH THE GERSHWIN PRIZE FOR
POPULAR SONG, THE NATION'S
HIGHEST HONOR FOR POPULAR SONG.
THE PRIZE IS NAMED AFTER THE
CELEBRATED SONGWRITING BROTHERS
GEORGE AND IRA GERSHWIN, WHOSE
COLLECTION IS AMONG THE 600 OR
SO COLLECTIONS IN THE MUSIC
DIVISION, ALONG WITH OTHERS LIKE
ROGERS AND HAMMERSTEIN, LEN
AROUND BEER STEIN, ALVIN AILEY,
MATCH ROACH AND BILLY STRAHORN.
I INVITE YOU TO COME AND EXPLORE
THESE COLLECTIONS.
IT IS FITTING WE OPEN THE WEEK
WITH THIS EVENT FEATURING 19
TIME GRAMMY AWARD WINNER EMILIO
ESTEFAN, BECAUSE HE STARTED THE
WHOLE THING, THE MIAMI-LATIN
FUSION SOUND.
AS YOU WILL HEAR IN TONIGHT'S
CONVERSATION WITH THE LIBRARIAN
OF CONGRESS CARLA HAYDEN, AND I
GUARANTEE THAT BY THE END OF THE
EVENING, YOU WILL BE CHARMED BY
HIS PERSONALITY AND DELIGHTED BY
HIS IMMIGRANT SUCCESS STORY.
FOR EMILIO, NOT ONLY SUCCEEDED
HIMSELF, HE ALSO BROUGHT OTHERS
ALONG AS HE SHAPED THE CAREERS
OF MANY MUSICAL SUPERSTARS,
INCLUDING THAT OF HIS WIFE.
THE LIBRARY'S OWN PERSONAL
SUPERSTAR, DR. CARLA HAYDEN,
WILL BE DOING THE INTERVIEW.
NOW, YOU ALL KNOW ABOUT THAT
QUESTION THAT YOU SOMETIMES GET
WHEN YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
THINKING AND IT SAYS --
IF YOU WERE TO INVITE PEOPLE TO
DINNER, WHO WOULD YOU INVITE?
WELL, THEY'D GET MY VOTE.
IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO FIND A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN TWO PEOPLE
WITH MORE OPTIMISM AND PASSION
FOR LIFE, SO GET READY.
THIS SHOULD BE FUN.
AND NOW, LET'S BRING OUT THE
LIBRARIAN OF CONGRESS, CARLA
HAYDEN, AND EMILIO ESTEFAN.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
YAY!
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> WELL, THIS IS SUCH A DELIGHT,
AND WE ARE SO PLEASED THAT YOU
ARE HERE, AND AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE, THOUGH, AS A LIBRARIAN,
I SAID:  HAS HE WRITTEN A BOOK?
HAS HE HAD ANY?
AND SO I CHECKED IT OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT BEFORE WE GET INTO THAT,
BECAUSE YOU CAN SEE I'VE TABBED
THINGS AND I WANTED TO ASK YOU
SOME THINGS, WHAT DOES THE
GERSHWIN PRIZE MEAN TO YOU?
>> OH MY GOD, AS A SONG WRITER
IT'S PROBABLY THE HIGHEST AWARD
YOU CAN GET.
IF MY MOM AND DAD WERE ALIVE
THEY WOULD NOT BELIEVE I AM HERE
TALKING TO YOU IN THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE AWARD BECAUSE
IT WAS SO DIFFICULT FOR US AT
THE BEGINNING COMING TO AMERICA
BECAUSE WE CAME WITH A DIFFERENT
SOUND AND A DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
IN A WAY AND IT WAS HARD.
IT WAS HARD BUT ONE THING I
ALWAYS FEEL PROUD, THAT THEY
OPENED THE DOORS TO US IN SUCH
AN INCREDIBLE WAY AND THEY
CLOSED A LOT OF DOORS AND SAID
THIS WILL NEVER WORK BUT WE
BELIEVED THAT WE HAVE SO MANY
GREAT PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND THEY OPENED A LOT OF
DOORS AND THE PEOPLE DECIDE,
WE'VE GOT SO MANY SONGS THAT
BECAME NUMBER ONE AND IT'S A
DREAM.
A DREAM TO GET THIS AWARD, FOR
ME AND GLORIA.
AND I WITH NOT SAY THANK YOU
ENOUGH AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY WHO DECIDED TO GIVE US
THIS AWARD.
SOME AWARDS STAY FOREVER IN YOUR
LIFE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU GET THE
MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
IT WAS AN INCREDIBLE SAID.
I ALWAYS SAID I WISH MY MOM AND
MY DAD WOULD BE ALIVE BECAUSE
THEY REALLY PUSHED ME IN A WAY
AND THEY TOLD ME ONE THING:  DO
WHAT MAKES YOU HAPPY AND THAT'S
WHAT I'VE DONE ALL MY LIFE.
DOING WHAT MADE ME HAPPY WAS
MAKING MUSIC AND IT'S A
BLESSING.
I AM VERY, VERY HONORED TO
RECEIVE THIS AWARD.
>> WE ARE MORE THAN PLEASED, AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE, BECAUSE YOUR
BOOK WAS A BEST-SELLER, TOO.
THE RHYTHM OF SUCCESS:  HOW AN
IMMIGRANT PRODUCED HIS OWN
AMERICAN DREAM.
AND YOUR DEDICATION IS TO ANY
YOUNG KID WITH THE DREAM OF
BECOMING THE FIRST HISPANIC
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> YEAH, YES.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
WE HAVE OVER 26 LATINOS AND
MILLENNIALS.
THEY'RE SO LUCKY TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WITH DREAMS.
EVERY DREAM CAN COME TRUE AS
LONG AS YOU DREAM AND DO WHAT IS
RIGHT FOR YOU AND I ALWAYS SAID
IN MY LIFE, THAT I HOPE MY
CAREER AND GLORIA'S CAREER IS
NOT ABOUT LATINOS ONLY, IT'S
ABOUT MINORITIES.
PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF DREAMS.
THEY DON'T HAVE MONEY.
THEY HAVE A DIFFERENT CULTURE,
AND THEY HAVE THE -- THEY HAVE
THE WAY TO DO AND BRING
SOMETHING THOROUGHLY NEW, AND
THEY NEVER FORGET WHERE THEY
CAME FROM.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
YOU'RE AFRICAN AMERICAN, YOU'RE
JEWISH, YOU'RE LATIN, LATINO,
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE MORE CULTURE,
IT'S GOOD TO SPEAK MORE
LANGUAGES.
THAT OPENS A LOT OF YOUR MIND, A
LOT OF THINGS.
MY DAD WAS FROM LEBANON AND MY
GRANDMOTHER USED TO TALK TO US
IN ARABIC AND I LEARNED A LOT OF
ARABIC BUT OF COURSE BEING IN
CUBA, I WAS BORN IN CUBA, AND OF
COURSE, IMPART HISPANIC AND I
TRY TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT OF
GOOD ENGLISH SO I HOPE YOU
UNDERSTAND.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'VE BEEN PRACTICING THE WHOLE
WEEK.
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND EVERYTHING
BUT YOU WILL ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS IN SPANISH BECAUSE ONE
OF YOUR, IN YOUR BOOK THE FOR
FORWORD WAS WRITTEN BY ONE OF
YOUR COLLEAGUES AND BEST
FRIENDS, MR. QUINCY JONES.
>> YES, OH MY GOD.
THAT WAS A DREAM.
QUINCY IS THE GODFATHER OF MY
DAUGHTER AND I LEARNED SO MUCH
FROM HIM BECAUSE I HAVE THE
HONOR HE'S GOING TO BE HERE WITH
US FOR THE AWARD.
QUINCY IS THE GUY THAT TEACH ME
A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT DREAMS.
IT WAS HARD FOR HIM, EVEN HE WAS
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE
DIFFERENT RACE, DIFFERENT COLOR.
I THINK WE NEED TO LEARN FROM
EACH OTHER AND WE NEED TO BE
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S
NOT ABOUT POLITICS.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN POLITICS.
BEING A DEMOCRAT OR A
REPUBLICAN, I BELIEVE WHO IS A
GOOD PERSON, AND HOW THEY -- HE
WENT THROUGH SUCH A HARD TIME IN
HIS LIFE AND HOW MUCH HE
ACCOMPLISHED AND HOW MUCH
CONTRIBUTION HE'S DONE FOR THE
WORLD, NOT ONLY MUSIC, TO THE
WORLD SO I'M VERY PROUD TO CALL
HIM MY COMPADRE AND MY FRIEND.
I LOVE QUINCY AND HE'S BEEN ONE
OF MY HEROES.
>> WHEN EMILIO WAS GROWING UP IN
THE U.S. THERE WERE NO LATIN
MUSIC MOGULS FOR HIM TO EMULATE.
HE HAD TO MAKE HIS OWN DREAM.
NOW, YOUR CHILDHOOD, THOUGH,
SOMEONE SAID YOU WENT FROM
RICHES TO RAGS TO RICHES.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
CHILDHOOD?
>> ABOUT, TALK ABOUT WHAT IS IN
THE BOOK, ABOUT THE --
>> AT 11 YOU SAID --
>> AT 11 YEARS OLD I WAS IN CUBA
AND I REALIZED THAT SOMEBODY
CAME TO THE HOUSE LOOKING FOR
DOLLARS BECAUSE THEY CHANGED THE
MONEY AND I REALIZED THAT THEY
WHEN I SAW PEOPLE COMING TO OUR
HOUSE WITH MACHINE GUNS AND
TRYING TO FORCE MY MOM AND MY
DAD TO SEARCH THE WHOLE HOUSE, I
WAS 11 YEARS OLD, BUT IT
IMPACTED MY LIFE BECAUSE I SAID
THE ONLY THING I REALLY DON'T
WANT IS TO STAY IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE EVEN WE LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED.
FREEDOM IS THE MAIN THING TO
HAVE, BECAUSE WITHOUT FREEDOM
YOU CAN'T HAVE DREAMS, YOU CAN'T
HAVE ANYTHING.
I DECIDE TO, I TOLD MY MOM THAT
NIGHT, I CRY ALL NIGHT.
I TOLD MY MOM I HAD TO LEAVE
CUBA IN ORDER TO LIVE BUT I KNEW
IT WAS THE ONLY CHANCE I HAVE
WITH MY FAMILY TO GET OUT OF
CUBA, AND I REMEMBER, I MEAN,
WHEN I GOT TO 14 IS WHEN THEY
LET ME LEAVE CUBA.
AND HAVING A BEAUTIFUL FAMILY
SORT OF, I MEAN, WELL, I BECAME,
I CRY ON THE PLANE FROM HAVANA
TO SPAIN.
I WENT TO SPAIN BECAUSE MY MOM
WAS FROM SPAIN.
AND WHEN I GOT THERE IN 8 HOURS,
I BECAME A MAN.
BEING A LITTLE KID, I BECAME A
MAN, AND I BECAME ALMOST
HOMELESS, BECAUSE WHEN YOU LEAVE
CUBA AT THE TIME YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO TAKE ANY MONEY,
ANYTHING, EVEN YOUR WATCH,
ANYTHING YOU HAVE, YOU HAVE TO
LEAVE EVERYTHING WITH THE
COUNTRY BUT I LEARN A LOT OF
THINGS.
A LOT OF THINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS IN LIFE.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT
IS REALLY HARD AND YOU HAVE TO
THINK, PLAN FOR THE FUTURE AND
THAT'S ONE THING I THINK I
LEARNED SO MANY THINGS HOW TO
ENJOY LIFE, HOW TO ENJOY EVERY
SINGLE MOMENT OF MY LIFE AND IT
WAS AN INCREDIBLE AND BEAUTIFUL
THING.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT IN YOUR BOOK,
AND I HAVE TO -- REQUIRED
READING.
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT'S, LIFE LESSONS AND SUCCESS,
AND EACH CHAPTER IS --
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
BE POSITIVE.
AND I HAVE TO SAY YOU'RE ONE OF
THE MOST POSITIVE PEOPLE I'VE
EVER MET.
AND YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO TURN
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS INTO
POSITIVE SITUATIONS, EVEN WHEN
YOU WERE FINDING THAT PEOPLE
WERE TELLING YOU:  THIS WILL
NEVER WORK.
YOU MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT AT
THE SONY COMPANY THAT HAPPENED
TO YOU.
I LOVE THIS ONE.
>> WELL, WHEN WE CAME AND WE
RECORD FIRST IN SPANISH -- WE
WERE THE FIRST GROUP BELIEVE IT
OR NOT TO DO AN ALBUM IN ENGLISH
AND SPANISH BILINGUAL AND THE
SONG BECAME NUMBER ONE WITH A
SMALL LABEL IN MIAMI.
THEN WE DID A SONG THAT IS
CALLED DR. BEAT.
DR. BEAT EVEN WE TOOK IT TO THE
LABEL SAYING THIS CALIFORNIA
KIND OF SOUND WILL NEVER WORK.
IT HAS A LOT OF PERCUSSION.
GLORIA SAID LET'S TRY OURSELF.
WE WENT TO THE RECORD POOLS, THE
DEEJAYS AND THE SONG BECAME
NUMBER ONE IN ENGLISH ENGLAND,
HOLLAND
AND IN THE STATES AND WE WERE SO
HAPPY, WE WENT TO HOLLAND AND
EVERYBODY WAS SO HAPPY ABOUT
THIS KIND OF SOUND.
PEOPLE JUMPING UP AND DOWN, IT
WAS FANTASTIC.
I REMEMBER WE HAVE ONLY TWO
SONGS IN ENGLISH AND THEY CAME
OUT, AND WE WANT MORE, WE WANT
MORE.
I SAID GLORIA, LET'S PLAY THE
CUBAN CONGAS.
THAT'S OKAY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH OR SPANISH.
I TALKED TO THE DRUM I AND THEY
WROTE A SOLD CONGA AND WE
RECORDED WITH A SMALL BUDGET THE
SONG.
AND I TRADE TO GO TO SONY AND
THEY SAY THEY ARE REALLY BUSY
AND FINALLY AFTER 7 TIMES THEY
LET ME COME INTO THE RECORD
LABEL, AND THE GUY WHO WAS THERE
SAID LISTEN, THIS SOUND WILL
NEVER WORK.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THE TRUMPETS
OUT, THE PERCUSSION OUT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S REALLY
ATTRACTED ME WAS HE SAID YOU
HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR LAST NAME.
AND I SAID, I NEVER WILL, SIR.
HE SAID YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
YOU HAVE TO PLAY THIS IN YOUR
HOME.
GO BACK TO YOUR COUNTRY AND I
TOLD THE GUY:  LISTEN, I'M PROUD
WHAT WE'VE DONE.
I'M PROUD OF MY FAMILY.
WE'LL DO IT ON OUR OWN.
AND YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
PROBABLY WE TRIED TO PUSH THE
LABEL JUST TO PUT IT OUT AND
THIS SONG BECAME THE NUMBER ONE
SONG IN EVERY FORMAT.
THE FUNNY THING THE SAME GUY
THAT WAS TELLING ME, THEY ARE
REALLY BUSY, 7 YEARS LATER I
BECAME PRESIDENT OF SONY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I LOVE THAT.
>> I USED TO COME IN AND SAY:
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU?
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> HE REMEMBERED YOU?
>> OH, HE REMEMBERED ME.
OH, BELIEVE ME, HE REMEMBERED
ME.
I REMEMBER HIM FOR SURE, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I REMEMBER HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
I NEVER FELT REGRET.
I FELT THAT SOMETHING,
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN MY
LIFE WAS FOR A REASON.
AND PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW THAT YOU
LEARN, MISTAKES, BECAUSE YOU
MAKE MISTAKES, SOMETIMES BECAUSE
A BAD EXPERIENCE, BUT IN YOUR
LIFE, PEOPLE REALIZE WHEN YOU
WAKE UP IN THE MORNING YOU'RE
ALIVE AND YOU HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
FAMILY.
YOU HAVE TO THANK GOD.
SAY I'M READY, LET ME WORK.
AND I DO THAT EVERY MORNING.
I THANK THE FANS.
I THANK EVERYBODY THAT GAVE US A
BEAUTIFUL LIFE AND LET US DO
WHAT WE LOVE ME AND GLORIA THAT
IS MAKING MUSIC.
I WOULDN'T HAVE IT ANY OTHER
CHOICE.
>> YOU MENTIONED PLANNING AND
WHEN YOU WAKE UP.
THERE'S A AN EFFORT TO ORGANIZE
AND DO THINGS, BUT YOU WERE WAY
AHEAD OF YOUR TIME.
ONE CHAPTER IS ABOUT PLANNING
AND IT GOES FROM THE MINUTE YOU
WAKE UP, YOU -- WELL, TELL THEM
ABOUT HOW YOU CAN SEE THINGS IN
THE DARK.
>> NO WONDER SHE'S THE BIG BOSS.
SHE KNOWS EVERYTHING.
>> YOU CAN FIND THINGS IN THE
DARK.
>> WHEN I ARRIVED IN THIS
COUNTRY I WAS EMOTIONLESS, I
FELT MY LIFE WAS DISORGANIZED.
I SPENT MANY YEARS WITHOUT
SEEING MY MOM AND I SAID HOW ARE
WE GOING TO MAKE MONEY?
HOW WILL WILL I BE ABLE TO HELP
MY FAMILY COME TO THIS COUNTRY?
I SAID THE ONLY WAY I'LL BE ABLE
TO MAKE MY LIFE SUCCESSFUL, IF I
GET ORGANIZED.
AND I DO PLANNING BECAUSE THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY YOU DO.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO FOCUS, YOU
SAY I HAVE A CHANCE, I LIVE IN A
COUNTRY THAT ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I SAY, I NEED TO WORK AND
THE THINGS, IT WAS HARD IN A WAY
BECAUSE WE NEVER WANTED TO LOSE
WHO WE ARE.
I THINK IT WAS THE SOUND, THAT'S
WHY WE CALL IT MIAMI SOUND
MACHINE BECAUSE WHEN WE CAME TO
MIAMI THERE WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
LEAVING CUBA BEING A COMMUNIST
COUNTRY, AND, BUT, YOU KNOW, I
GREW UP LISTENING TO CRUZ AND
ALL THE CUBAN MUSIC AND THEN I
COME TO MIAMI AND YOU GET MOTOWN
AND DONNA SUMMER AND ALL THE
GREAT MUSIC IN THIS COUNTRY AND
WE COMBINED BOTH ELEMENTS.
THE RECORD LABELS NEVER LIKE TO
TAKE CHANCES BUT I SAY I DON'T
WANT TO CHANGE SOMETHING THAT IS
NOT WHO WE ARE.
IT'S ONE THING I LEAVE TO MY
KIDS AND TO, I THINK TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE IS THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO CHANGE YOURSELF TO
BE SUCCESSFUL.
YOU HAVE TO BE WHO YOU ARE.
YOU ARE REAL AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SMART AND THEY KNOW
WHEN YOU DO SOMETHING WITH A LOT
OF HONESTY AND I FEEL PROUD
ABOUT THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> SO BEFORE YOU, THERE WASN'T A
TRUE MIAMI SOUND.
YOU DEVELOPED THAT?
>> IT WAS THE MIAMI SOUND.
THEY TOLD ME DON'T PUT THAT
SOUND.
THAT'S THE LOCAL.
I SAID THAT'S WHO WE ARE, MIAMI
SOUND.
I USED TO WRITE SOMETHING IN
HAMBURGER, THE WHOLE FUSION.
>> SO THE BUSINESS PART, YOU GOT
INTO PRODUCING AND HELPING OTHER
ARTISTS.
>> YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
WHEN MY SON, OF COURSE WE START
DOING WITH GLORIA ALL THE ALBUMS
AND WE KNEW WHAT WE WAS LACKING
FOR.
WE NOW WE WOULD LIKE TRUMPETS
AND WE LIKE THE PERCUSSION AND
WE LIKE THAT, BUT THEN WE BECAME
THANK GOD VERY SUCCESSFUL AND
ALLOWED MANY PEOPLE CAME AND
ASKED ME, LATINO, LIKE DELIA FOR
EXAMPLE BUT JOHN SACATA CAME.
I SAID YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
YOU'RE BILINGUAL AND YOU CAN DO
IT.
WE DID AN ALBUM.
EVEN AFTER ALL THE SUCCESS WE
GOT WITH CON GEORGIA AND --
CONGA
CAME, SO WE WAS PLAYING WEMBLY
IN LONDON.
I SAID I HAVE A GUY THAT'S
FANTASTIC.
THE GUY SAID LISTEN I'M GOING TO
BE -- LISTEN, I TOLD HIM YOU
HAVE THE CONGA.
YOU CAN COME IN THE MORNING AND
LEAVE THE NEXT DAY.
I CONVINCED HIM.
I THINK ENERGY IS SO IMPORTANT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT POSITIVE.
I SAY YES YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO
HIM BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY I AM.
TOMORROW I'M GOING TO WEAR THE
NEW TIE, I'M SO HAPPY LIKE A
KID.
THAT'S CONTAGIOUS.
SOMEBODY WHO'S DEPRESSED GET
DEPRESSED.
WHEN YOU'RE HAPPY EVERYBODY GET
HAPPY.
THAT'S ME.
I CANNOT AVOID THAT.
GLORIA WILL SAY I LOVE LUCY, BUT
I'M LUCY, THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YES, TELL ME ABOUT HOW YOU
PLAN THINGS AND PACK AND ALL
THAT.
>> HOW I PACK?
OH, MY GOD.
I'M THE BEST PACKER IN THE
WORLD.
I CAN GET MY UNDERWEAR AND --
>> IN THE DARK.
YES.
I'M GETTING RED.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> BUT THAT'S THE PLANNING AND
BEING READY.
NOW, GLORIA, HOW DID YOU MEET
GLORIA?
>> HOW I MET GLORIA, WHEN I CAME
TO MIAMI, I -- FIRST THING THAT
I DID, I CONVINCED MY UNCLE, I
SAID UNCLE I NEED TO BUY AN
ACCORDION.
HE SAID I DON'T HAVE MONEY.
PLEASE SIGN FOR ME THE
ACCORDION, IT WAS $177.
MY AUNT TOLD ME HOW WE GONNA PAY
FOR THIS?
I'M GOING TO SEE.
THEN I WENT TO AN ITALIAN
RESTAURANT.
A CUBAN GUY PLAGUE ITALIAN
MUSIC, THAT'S REALLY WEIRD.
>> ON AN ACCORDION.
>> I HIRED THE ACCORDION.
I WORKED FOR THE BACARDI FAMILY
AND I NEWSED TO KNOW THE CUBAN
MUSIC SO THE BACARDI FAMILY CAME
FROM CUBA, THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A WEDDING AND PARTY, THE
RECEPTION, AND ANNIVERSARY.
AND WE WANTED YOU TO COME WITH
ACCORDION AND MAYBE A PERCUSSION
AND I CAME AND WE PLAYED THAT
NIGHT AND WE BECAME A HUGE
SUCCESS.
THEY TIPPED ME LIKE 120 BUCKS.
THAT WAS LIKE OH MY GOD, I'M
BLESSED, I'M SO HAPPY.
I CAN BUY SOMETHING TOMORROW.
AND THE BAND BECAME REALLY
FAMOUS, CALLED MIAMI LATIN BOYS.
I USED TO WORK WITH BACARDI.
HE SAID THERE'S A GROUP THAT'S
GOING TO PERFORM IN THE CHURCH
AND YOU SHOULD COME TO LISTEN TO
THEM BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY'RE GOOD ENOUGH TO DO THAT,
TO COLLECT MONEY FOR POOR
PEOPLE.
SO I WENT TO THE HOUSE AND I SAW
THIS GROUP PERFORMING.
I SAW GLORIA.
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED.
NUMBER ONE, I LOVE THE WAY, THE
HONESTY ON HER.
GLORIA IS AN INCREDIBLE HUMAN
BEING AND I SAW SHE WAS A LITTLE
BIT SORT OF BEAUTIFUL VOICE BUT
SHE WAS SORT OF LIKE SAD IN A
WAY.
GLORIA SAID HER CHILDHOOD WASN'T
GOOD.
HER FATHER WENT TO BAY OF PIGS,
IT WAS AN INVASION, THEN HE CAME
BACK AND WENT TO VIETNAM AND
WHEN HE CAME BACK, HE CAME IN A
WHEELCHAIR SO I KNEW SOMETHING
WAS -- IT WAS A FEELING.
SOMETIMES YOU FEEL PEOPLE.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
THAT DAY I SAY HELLO, GOODBYE
AND THREE MONTHS LATER I WAS
PLAYING A WEDDING AND SHE CAME
INTO THE WEDDING.
I WAS PLAYING THE ACCORDION.
AND GLORIA WAS IMPRESSED WITH
THAT.
SHE SAID OH MY GOD, A CUBAN GUY
PLAYING THE HUSTLE, THAT'S
REALLY WEIRD.
I SAID COME AND SING A SONG WITH
US AND SHE CAME AND SHE DIDN'T
WANT TO DO IT.
I SAID COME ON, EVERYBODY KNOWS
YOU HERE AND WE PLAYED TWO SONGS
AND I LOVED HER VOICE.
I SAID WE DO THIS WEEKEND, WE
USED TO PLAY WEDDINGS, BAR
MITZVAHS WE PLAY EVERYTHING IN
MIAMI AND THEN I LOVE THE SOUND
TO BE BILINGUAL, TO HAVE
PERCUSSION, TO HAVE DANCE MUSIC.
AND SHE CAME, FOR THE AUDITION
SHE CAME WITH THE GRANDMOTHER,
THE MOTHER, HER SISTER,
EVERYBODY CAME TO THE PLACE WE
WAS REHEARSING.
I'M LIKE OH MY GOD.
IN CUBAN WE CALL CHAPERONE.
HAVE TO HAVE CHAPERONE ALL THE
TIME.
THAT'S WHEN YOU GET A BODY GUARD
FOR THE GIRL YOU'RE DATING.
NOT NOW.
THINGS CHANGE.
BUT AT THE TIME, YOU KNOW, I MET
GLORIA, IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE A
GIRLFRIEND, YOU HAVE A CHAPERONE
LIKE A BODY GUARD NEXT TO HER.
SO SHE SAID, LISTEN, I'M GOING
TO DO IT AND MAY COUSIN WILL
COME WITH ME.
I SAID OKAY, DOESN'T MATTER.
WE HARDLY MAKE NO MONEY, IT WAS
$125 WE USED TO PLAY PARTIES.
SHE SAID SHE SAID WE'LL SPLIT
THE WHOLE MONEY.
WE USED TO MAKE PROBABLY 20
BUCKS.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
ONE OF THE THINGS I NOTICED EVEN
WHEN I WAS GOING THROUGH A HARD
TIME, WHEN I USED TO PERFORM
WITH THE BAND EVERY WEEKEND, IT
WAS THE HAPPIEST MOMENTS, AND I
KNEW AND THEN THE WHOLE THING, I
SAID LET'S MAKE A RECORD.
WE STARTED RECORDING THE RECORD
AND THE FIRST ONE WE RECORDED
BECAME NUMBER ONE IN THE SPANISH
MARKET.
ALL LATIN AMERICA AND THE UNITED
STATES.
AND WE BECAME REALLY FAMOUS AND
THEN SONY CALLED, AND WE GOT
A -- WE WAS INVOLVED WITH A
LOCAL LABEL, AND WE HAVE TO BUY
THE RIGHTS FOR THE LOCAL LABEL.
WE BOUGHT THE RIGHTS FOR THE
PUBLISHING COMPANY AND FOR
THE -- THEY LET US GO.
THEY SAID IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU WANT TO GO ON?
HE'S GOT THE MONEY I PUT INTO
THE RECORD, I PAID.
WE SIGNED THE DEAL WITH SONY, WE
DID CONGA AND IT WAS A BLESSING
IN THE WAY BUT IT WAS DIFFICULT.
DIFFICULT THAT'S WHAT I THINK,
NOWADAYS I WOULD HAVE SO MANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MUSIC BUSINESS
BECAUSE THE DOWNLOADING, I SAID
GUYS LISTEN, YOU'LL HAVE THE
INTERNET AND YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
SHOW YOUR MUSIC WORLDWIDE NOW.
DON'T LOSE THE MOMENT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE TRY TO PLAY AT
HOME, JUST GET YOUR TELEPHONE
AND GET THEM TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING.
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GOOD, PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO LIKE YOU.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING IS HAPPENING,
LITTLE BY LITTLE BUT IT'S
HAPPENING BUT IT'S BEEN A ROUGH
TIME FOR A LOT OF MUSICIANS AND
THE REASON I ALWAYS SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE IT WAS SO HARD FOR ME
AND GLORIA AND SOMETIMES WHEN I
SEE GLORIA IS NUMBER ONE, I SAY
OH MY GOD, WHO COULD HAVE
BELIEVED WHEN WE STARTED, PEOPLE
SAID NO, NO, IT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN BUT WITH ME AND GLORY IT
WAS OUR PERSISTENCE AND TRY TO
DO, YOU KNOW -- THE OTHER THING
YOU DO WITH SONGS LIKE CONGA,
THEY WANT THE LABEL TO ONLY DO
CONGA, THEY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE
FOR A BALLAD.
I SAID WE WANT TO PLAY A BALLAD.
SO IT WAS HARD FOR US AT THE
BEGINNING BECAUSE THEY SAID WE
DON'T WANT TO BACK YOU UP WITH
CONGA AND YOU COME WITH A
BALLAD.
AND THEY DIDN'T WANT TO PUT ANY
MONEY BECAUSE THEY SAY WHY THE
BALLAD?
DO WHAT MAKES YOU HAPPY.
DON'T TELL ANYBODY KNOW.
DON'T LET ANYBODY CHANGE YOUR
DESTINY BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE GET
THEIR DESTINY CHANGED BECAUSE
SOMEBODY CAN FORCE YOU TO DO
SOMETHING YOU DON'T WANT TO DO.
>> NOW, THE FIRST KISS, THOUGH,
LET'S GET BACK TO YOU AND
GLORIA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M TELLING YOU, SHE KNOWS
EVERYTHING.
SHE'S KEEPING ALL THE SECRETS
HERE.
>> BECAUSE THERE WAS A LITTLE
SOMETHING GOING ON WITH THE
FIRST KISS.
>> YEAH.
I LIKE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I DON'T BELIEVE IN LOVE AT FIRST
SIGHT.
LOVE HAS TO DO WITH SOMEBODY
WHEN YOU BLAKE THE DECISION TO
SPEND YOUR LIFE, IT HAS TO BE
SOMEBODY YOU WANT TO SPEND YOUR
LIFE.
I'VE BEEN MARRIED OVER 40 YEARS
AND IT'S THE BEST MARRIAGE OF MY
LIFE.
IT'S BEEN UNBELIEVABLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> 40 YEARS.
>> GLORIA USED TO RIDE WITH ME
IN THE BAND TO SET UP THE
EQUIPMENT.
YOU AND ME WE GET MARRIED WE BE
REALLY GOOD.
AND GLORIA LOOK AT ME AND SAY
WHAT THE HELL IS HE TALKING
ABOUT?
SO IT WAS JULY 4, 1976 AND WAS
ALL THE FIREWORKS.
AND I TOLD GLORIA, GLORIA, THE
4th IS MY BIRTHDAY.
SHE SAID OH, MY GOD, JULY 4th?
YES.
WILL YOU GIVE ME A KISS?
WELL, NO, I GIVE YOU A PRESENT.
NO, NO, GIVE ME A KISS, BABY,
COME ON.
JUST A KISS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I SAID OKAY, GIVE ME A PRESENT.
BUT GIVE ME A KISS NOW.
SO THE FIREWORKS IS GOING, THE
WHOLE THING.
>> BUT THAT'S NOT YOUR BIRTHDAY.
>> NO, I TOLD HER WHEN SHE GAVE
ME THE KISS I SAID IT'S THE
4th OF MARCH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT IT WORKED.
IT WORKED.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO LIE A
LITTLE BIT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
>> I'M FRAY AID WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE PAGE WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY NOW.
>> 40 SOMETHING ELSE.
>> 40 YEARS.
>> CHAPTER 26, FOCUS WHEN
DISASTER STRIKES, THAT WAS A
HARD TIME.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
WE WORKED SO HARD AND A LOT OF
DREAMS AND WE WAS ENJOYING LIFE
AND WHEN WE GOT INTO THE
ACCIDENT, THEY TOLD ME THAT
GLORIA PROBABLY WOULD NEVER WALK
AGAIN.
SHE WAS -- SHE BROKE HER BACK.
AND I SAID, AND THAT'S WHAT WE
CALL A PLAY ON YOUR FEELINGS.
DOESN'T MATTER IF YOU'RE RICH
AND FAMOUS.
A LOT OF THINGS HAPPEN IN YOUR
LIFE, YOU HAVE TO GET ON YOUR
FEET WHEN YOU GO THROUGH A
DIFFICULT TIME.
EVERYBODY GOES THROUGH DIFFICULT
TIMES.
MAYBE SOMEBODY IS SICK, SOMEBODY
DIES.
YOU HAVE TO LAND ON YOUR FEET.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
I WAS LOOKING AT A PICTURE,
DOING THE PACKAGES FOR THE
TELECAST.
THE DAY THAT THE ACCIDENT
HAPPENED, I WAS THOROUGHLY BLACK
HAIR.
THREE MONTHS LATER I WAS TOTALLY
WHITE.
I BECAME TOTALLY GRAY, BECAUSE I
SAID IT WAS SO DIFFICULT FOR US
AND SHE WAS SO DETERMINED TO GO
BACK.
SAY, I WANT TO INSPIRE PEOPLE.
IF YOU'RE OKAY AND MY BABY IS
OKAY, I'LL BE OKAY AND IT WAS
REALLY TOUGH.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
ONE YEAR LATER SHE WAS ON THE
STAGE AND SHE WAS GOING ON A
WORLD TOUR AND IT WAS A BLESSING
OF BEING PERSISTENT.
GLORIA IS A VERY POSITIVE
PERSON, AND I ALWAYS RESPECTED
HER AND ADMIRE HER.
I THINK I ADMIRE HER MORE
BECAUSE SHE WAS A ROLE MODEL FOR
ME WHEN THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE
SHE BECAME SO STRONG BECAUSE OF
THE KID AND THE FAMILY.
SHE KNEW HOW HARD IT WAS TO SEE
A PERSON IN A WHEELCHAIR BECAUSE
SHE DEAL WITH HER FATHER IN THAT
SITUATION.
SO AFTER THAT, YOU KNOW
SOMETHING?
I LOVE LIFE AND I EVEN LOVE LIFE
MORE BECAUSE I REALIZE HOW LUCKY
WE ARE AND I ALWAYS THANK PEOPLE
THAT PRAY FOR US SO MUCH AND
GIVE US THE SUPPORT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE SUPPORT AT THAT
TIME IN OUR LIFE.
>> AND IN TERMS OF RESPECT OF
THAT MIAMI SOUND, WHEN YOU WERE
TOLD, THIS WILL NEVER WORK AND
EVERYTHING, YOU PERSISTED.
YOU WENT AHEAD AND THEN YOU
STARTED PRODUCING.
WHO ARE SOME OF THE PEOPLE AND
THE GROUPS THAT YOU WORKED WITH
THAT'S LEGENDARY?
>> THE FIRST ONE WAS JOHN SECATA
BUT THEN JENNIFER LOPEZ WHEN SHE
CAME TO ME, MARK ANTHONY,
SHAKIRA, RICKY MARINATE, IT WAS
A BLESSING IN A -- RICKY MARTIN.
IT WAS A BLESSING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHEN THEY HAVE A
SOUND THEY DON'T WANT TO SHARE
WITH SOMEBODY ELSE, WE GOT LUCKY
AND I ALWAYS BELIEVE IN KARMA.
WHAT YOU GET IS WHAT YOU GIVE,
AND HELPING THEM NOT ONLY WAS A
GREAT MOVE FOR MY CAREER, IT WAS
A GREAT BLESSING TO OUR CULTURE
AND TO KEEP OPENING THE DOOR FOR
A LOT OF KIDS.
A LOT OF KID HAVE COME TO THIS
COUNTRY THAT THEY COME WITH
DREAMS.
AND THEY SEE SOMEBODY ELSE DOING
IT.
TONIGHT THIS AWARD WE'RE
GETTING, I HOPE LIKE I SAID, IT
CAN TOUCH MANY PEOPLE'S LIFE,
AND MANY KIDS AND PEOPLE, AND
WHEN I SAY IT, I MEAN NOT
LATINOS, MINORITIES.
I SAY THAT OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME THAT I
SAW THE GRAMMYS.
I SAID I'M GOING TO SAVE MONEY
ONE DAY TO GO TO THE GRAMMYS.
THAT MR. MY DREAM.
8 YEARS LATER I WAS ON THE FIRST
ROW COMPETING AGAINST QUINCY
JONES.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT.
I'VE BEEN THERE ALMOST 42 TIMES.
WHO COULD HAVE SAID THAT?
AND THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CINDY LAUPER AND PATTY
LABELLE.
>> EVERYBODY IS COMING.
THAT'S FANTASTIC.
>> AND JUST, IT EXPANDS AND IT'S
UNIVERSAL.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
THAT SHOW REPRESENTS US.
PATTY LABELLE, CINDY LAUPER,
JOSÉ F.
LICIANO MIKES DAUGHTER IS GOING
TO PERFORM.
I'M THE BIGGEST FAN OF MY
DAUGHTER.
GLORIA IS GOING TO SING.
I'M GOING TO PLAY CONGAS.
>> IT SHOULD BE WONDERFUL.
ONE THING THAT COMES THANK YOU
IN YOUR BOOK, EACH CHAPTER IS
ABOUT A DIFFERENT ASPECT OF
BUSINESS AND LIFE.
PEOPLE SOMETIMES DON'T REALIZE
WHAT A PRODUCER DOES.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT --
>> PRODUCER IS LIKE A COACH.
A COACH IN A, WHEN YOU SEE A
FOOTBALL, AND THEY'RE TELLING
ALL THIS, A PRODUCER IS IN
CHARGE FROM BEGINNING TO END.
PICK UP THE SONGS, WHAT KEY IT'S
GOING TO BE.
MANAGE THE BUDGET, WHAT TEMPO IS
SO MANY DIFFERENT ELEMENTS.
ALL THE THINGS FOR THE UNIONS,
YOU KNOW, GET EVERYTHING READY
AND THEN MAKES THE WHOLE ALBUM,
GET IT READY.
SO IT TAKES IT FROM BEGINNING TO
END.
LIKE WHEN YOU PRODUCE A MOVIE.
I WORK ON A LOT OF MOVIES.
I WORKED, I DID A SONG FOR THREE
MEN AND A BABY.
POCAHONTAS.
A MUSIC PRODUCER THEY GIVE ME
ONLY THE IMAGES WITHOUT MUSIC SO
I HAVE TO CREATE MOST OF THE
MUSIC, THE MUSIC FOR THE MOVIE.
SO THAT'S WHAT THE PRODUCER
DOES.
TRYING TO FIND A UNIQUE SOUND.
WHEN I PRODUCED RICKY MARTIN
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE SHAKIRA, OR
NOBODY HAS THE SOUND OF GLORIA'S
SOUND.
TO ME I WAS LOOKING OUT BECAUSE
I PRODUCE ALL THESE PEOPLE,
CARLOS BIBE, CASTRO, ALEJANDRO
FERNANDEZ, SOME OTHERS FROM
BRAZIL, I LOVE WHEN A PRODUCER
DOES DIFFERENT MUSIC BECAUSE
WHAT PEOPLE NEVER KNOW, I NEVER
GOT STUDIED MUSIC.
EVERYTHING I GOT MUSIC IT'S
BECAUSE I WANTED TO LEARN MUSIC
AND TO WRITE MUSIC AND TO
PRODUCE AND EVERYTHING BUT I
NEVER WENT TO SCHOOL FOR THAT.
THAT'S WHAT I TELL PEOPLE,
SCHOOL IS A GREAT THING TO
HAPPEN, LIKE I TELL MAY DAUGHTER
SHE WENT TO BERKELEY BUT THAT'S
NOT THE MAIN THING.
IT'S ABOUT THE PASSION YOU HAVE
TO DO THINGS THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO DO SOMETHING THAT MAKES YOU
REALLY, REALLY HAPPY.
IN A WAY I WAS SO LUCKY THAT I
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT.
>> YOU MENTIONED YOU DETERMINE
THE KEY THAT AN EARTHIST SINGS
IN?
HOW DOES -- ARTIST SINGS IN?
>> FERNANDEZ FROM MEXICO HE HAD
A BEAUTIFUL VOICE BUT THE KEY
WAS REALLY LOW.
HE SOUNDED TOO DEEP.
THEN I CHANGED THE KEY TO A
BRIGHTER KEY AND THE SONG
BECOMES MORE PRESENT.
THAT'S WHAT A PRODUCER, WHO
PRODUCES, OVERALL NOW, BEING A
PRODUCER I MANAGED SHAKIRA FOR
11 YEARS.
I WORKED WITH GLORIA.
I MANAGED JOHN SECATA FOR 20
YEARS.
HE'S LIKE MY BROTHER.
IT'S NOT ONLY WHEN YOU FINISH AN
ALBUM, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ORGANIZE?
WHEN I STARTED DOING MUSIC THERE
WAS NO INTERNET.
HOW ARE WE ABLE TO PROMOTE
WORLDWIDE MUSIC?
WITH GLORIA SOMETIMES WE USED TO
HAVE BREAKFAST IN PARIS, LUNCH
IN ITALY AND SLEEP IN GERMANY.
YOU ONLY HAVE A MONTH TO PROMOTE
AN ALBUM WORLDWIDE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S RECORDED IN
4 OR 5 DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
YOU HAVE TO HIT DIFFERENT
MARKETS, THE SPANISH MARKET, THE
ENGLISH MARKET AND IN THE
SPANISH MARKET WE HAVE CROSS-
CROSS-OVER.
DOMINICAN USIC IS DIFFERENT FROM
SALSA.
BRAZILIAN MUSIC IS DIFFERENT SO
WE WAS PROBABLY AS A PRODUCER
WAS ONE OF THE FEW FIRST
PRODUCERS TO DO A SONG THAT
TRANSLATE TO EVERY SINGLE LATIN
MARKET, BEFORE I WAS A PRODUCER
YOU HAD TO DO THE MEXICAN
VERSION, THE PUERTO RICAN
VERSION, AND IT'S LIKE ANOTHER
ALBUM.
I MIX A LOT OF THINGS.
I THINK LIKE I WAS SAYING AT THE
BEGINNING, WHEN YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT CULTURES, YOU LEARN SO
MUCH FROM DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE, MUSIC HAS NO LANGUAGE.
IT'S ABOUT THE ENERGY YOU PUT
INTO THE RECORD, THE MESSAGE YOU
WANT TO SEND.
AND I REMEMBER WHEN I DID A SONG
IN SPANISH AND I IN THE MIDDLE
PUT BLACKEYED PEA, IT WAS SUCH
AN INCREDIBLE FEEL BECAUSE I
BROUGHT PEOPLE, PEOPLE LISTEN TO
DIFFERENT, SOMEBODY WHO I ADORE
AND RESPECT.
HERE WAS THE FLAVOR OF MIAMI AND
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
MOTOWN HAS A FLAVOR.
MIAMI HAS THEIR OWN FLAVOR AND
THAT GOES WORLDWIDE AND THAT'S A
BEAUTIFUL THING.
>> CAN YOU REMEMBER THE FIRST
TIME YOU HEARD YOUR FIRST SONG
ON THE RADIO?
>> IN THE RADIO?
I STOP THE CAR, I STILL COULDN'T
BELIEVE THAT.
OH, MY GOD, GLORIA, WE'RE ON THE
RADIO.
WE'RE ON THE RADIO!
YOU KNOW, BELIEVE IT OR NOT IT'S
STILL NOW WHEN I DO A SONG I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH, I JUST HAD A GROUP
FROM ITALY THAT WAS THREE TENORS
AND THEY WENT TO NUMBER 3 ON THE
CHARTS AND IT WAS -- WHEN I
HEARD THEM FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE SONG ON THE RADIO, NOW AFTER
SO MANY YEARS, I STILL HAVE THE
SAME FEELING.
I ALWAYS SAID YOU KNOW
SOMETHING, I ALWAYS WANT TO MAKE
MUSIC, IT'S LIKE MY FIRST ALBUM
WHEN I DID IT OR THE LAST ONE
I'M GOING TO DO BECAUSE I FEEL
IF YOU LOSE THAT ENERGY, IT
DOESN'T COME THROUGH THE WAY IT
SHOULD BE.
>> SO YOU STILL FEEL THE TINGLE
OR THE EXCITEMENT.
>> FOR SURE.
EVEN WHEN I BUY A TIE, I TOLD
YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU ALSO THOUGH HAVE BEEN
DOING THINGS IN PHILANTHROPY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS, TOO.
>> YES.
>> SO COULD YOU TELL A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT.
>> WHEN I COME TO THIS COUNTRY,
I THINK WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE TO GIVE BACK, HOW LUCKY
WE ARE THAT WE LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, THAT GIVE US
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A LIVING, TO
BE FREE AND IN THE END GLORIA WE
COMMIT OURSELVES, WE DO A LOT OF
CHARITY, A LOT OF THINGS AND
EVERY TIME THERE'S A PROBLEM
WITH HUMAN RIGHTS AND THINGS, WE
ALWAYS TRY TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
PEOPLE, AND ESPECIALLY THINGS
HAPPEN LIKE IN VENEZUELA AND
CUBA THAT WE STILL HAVE HUMAN
RIGHTS PROBLEM.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
PEOPLE TO KNOW THAT WHEN YOU SEE
EVERY TIME THIS KIND OF THING
HAPPENED, THEY DON'T HAVE
FREEDOM, YOU SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN VENEZUELA
NOW IS A HORRIBLE THING.
YOU SEE KIDS DYING AND PEOPLE
DYING OF HUNGER.
WHAT HAPPENED TO CUBA IS STILL
HAPPENING IN CUBA IS A MAJOR
PROBLEM AND WE -- I HOPE BEFORE
I LEAVE THIS COUNTRY, AND THIS
WORLD, I HOPE THAT I SEE A WORLD
WITH FREEDOM IN EVERY PLACE IN
THE WORLD BECAUSE OH AND PEACE
BECAUSE WE GO TO THE MOON AND WE
DON'T REALIZE WE HAVE TO FIX
WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I REALLY WANT TO HEAR MORE
ABOUT THAT --
>> SHE CLOSED THE BOOK.
>> OH, NO, BECAUSE YOU ENDED UP
WITH GETTING FIRED, WHEN YOU'RE
HERE WITH SO -- AND LOOKING INTO
THE FUTURE.
IN TERMS OF THE MUSIC BUSINESS
AND JUST WHAT YOU THINK, WHAT DO
YOU SEE?
YOU MENTIONED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE INTERNET AND --
>> IT'S A LOT OF THINGS
HAPPENING.
THAT'S WHY YOU NEED TO BE
ORGANIZED.
WHATEVER YOU DO NOW IS EXTREMELY
-- I THINK BEING
ORGANIZED HELP YOU A LOT.
MAKING PLANS, ANYTHING, I THINK
A LOT OF PEOPLE BECOME
SUCCESSFUL AND A LOT OF PEOPLE
THEY DON'T BECOME SUCCESSFUL
BECAUSE THEY DO THINGS IN A
HURRY.
EVEN GETTING MARRIED, DON'T GET
MARRIED IN A HURRY.
TAKE YOUR TIME.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN YOU GET MARRIED
BE SURE YOU TELL YOUR WIFE YES
TO EVERYTHING SHE TELLS YOU,
THEN YOU'LL BE MARRIED FOR 41
YEARS.
IT'S A LOT OF GREAT THINGS
HAPPENING.
THE MUSIC BUSINESS IS GOING
THROUGH A REALLY ROUGH TIME
BECAUSE OF THE DOWNLOADING
SITUATION THAT PEOPLE DON'T PAY
AND I WAS TALKING TO SOME OF
YOUR PEOPLE, BY THE WAY
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU HAVE ONE OF THE MORE
BEAUTIFUL STAFF.
HOW MUCH RESPECT THEY HAVE FOR
YOU.
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED WITH
THE RECORD BUSINESS AFFECTED NOT
ONLY THE MUSICIANS, IT'S
AFFECTED PEOPLE WHO CLEAN THE
STUDIO, THE PEOPLE, THE
ENGINEERS, THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DISTRIBUTION, THE PEOPLE WHO
STOCK THINGS IN THE WAREHOUSE TO
SELL THE RECORDS, IT'S REALLY
AFFECTED A LOT OF PEOPLE SO I
HOPE THEY FIND A WAY THAT WE CAN
KEEP MAKING LIFE MUSIC.
MUSIC IS SOMETHING THAT BRINGS A
LOT OF JOY TO THE WORLD AND I
HOPE WE FIND A WAY GO ABLE TO --
WE JUST GOT IN BIG LITIGATION
THAT THINGS A LOT OF US THAT
WORKED ON THAT IN THE PAST TO
BE ABLE TO WHEN YOU DOWNLOAD
SOMETHING AT LEAST THEY GET PAID
A LITTLE BIT AND MAKE A LIVING
BUT I THINK SOMETHING, I ALWAYS
LOOK AT THE BRIGHT SIDE.
I THINK THE COMPUTER IS GOING TO
BE FANTASTIC.
THEY NEED TO LEARN HOW TO MUSIC.
NOWADAYS WITH THE PHONE YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR OWN VIDEO.
YOU DON'T NEED TO MAKE, LIKE, A
MILLION DOLLAR VIDEO.
YOU MAKE A VIDEO THAT IS
SINCERE, CREATE YOUR OWN SOUND,
CREATE A SONG THAT'S VERY UNIQUE
THAT NOBODY'S DONE BEFORE.
DON'T TRY TO COPY ANYBODY WHEN
YOU DO NEWSIC.
DO SOMETHING THAT IS YOU AND IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU'RE AFRICAN DO AFRICAN MUSIC,
IF YOU'RE FRENCH, DO FRENCH BUT
JUST BE REAL.
THAT'S SOMETHING I LEARNED MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO.
>> YOU HAVE TO BE YOURSELF.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> WELL, WE ARE GOING TO
ACTUALLY OPEN IT UP A LITTLE BIT
FOR QUESTION AND ANSWER.
>> YOU TOLD ME TO SPEAK SPANISH.
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
AND I SAID -- YES, BECAUSE THIS
IS BEING LIVESTREAMED WORLDWIDE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO PLEASE --
>> WHEN I SAW HER, I LOVE WHEN I
DO THIS THING.
PEOPLE HAVE QUESTIONS, THAT
SOMETIMES THEY WANT TO ASK ME.
YOU HAVE ANY KIND OF QUESTION IF
YOU DON'T MIND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ANYBODY WHO HAS A QUESTION,
I WOULD LOVE TO ANSWER YOU.
>> AND SO WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT
UP A LITTLE BIT.
AND WE HAVE A HAND UP HERE, AND
MICS ARE COMING AROUND.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> AND WE OH.
>> I LOVE YOU THE CONGA ALBUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THAT'S A FIRST.
OH, MY.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO DO IT.
>> HI.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA.
MAY QUESTION -- I'M DOWN HERE.
>> OH, RIGHT THERE.
>> RIGHT HERE.
RECENTLY YOU BOTH BROUGHT A
MUSICAL TO WASHINGTON, D.C.
CAN YOU TALK MORE ABOUT THAT,
AND, LIKE, WAS IT A NEW -- DID
IT FEEL LIKE A NEW PROJECT AND
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU HAD TO
DO WITH IT?
>> YEAH, THE MUSIC BEEN, WE'RE
SO LUCKY IT WAS ON BROADWAY FOR
SO LONG BUT NOW IT'S IN JAPAN.
BUT IT WAS IN HOLLAND AND IT'S
GOING TO OPEN NOW IN WEST END OF
LONDON AND WE'RE STILL TOURING
THE STATE.
VERY SUCCESSFUL TOUR.
IT SENDS A GREAT MESSAGE ABOUT
LOVE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU GOT TO SEE
IT.
YEAH?
I THINK IT'S IN THE WORKS TO
MAYBE DO A MOVIE SOON SO GET
READY FOR THE MOVIE NOW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT'S A SNEAK PREVIEW THERE.
WHO WILL PLAY YOU NOW?
>> AND THANK YOU FOR GOING.
>> I THINK WE HAVE SOME RIGHT
THERE.
>> THERE'S SO MANY THINGS YOU'VE
ACHIEVED TOGETHER WITH GLORIA.
WHAT IS YOUR OTHER BIGGEST
DREAMS?
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER DREAMS ABOUT
BIG PROJECTS?
>> WILL YOU SAY THAT AGAIN?
BECAUSE IT WAS HARD TO --
>> AFTER SO MUCH YOU HAVE
ACHIEVED, DO YOU HAVE THE
BIGGEST DREAM TO ACHIEVE
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> OH, MY GOD, I CAN'T ASK FOR
MORE.
I WOULD BE GREEDY IF I ASK FOR
MORE THAN I'VE DONE MY WHOLE
LIFE.
KEEP MY FAMILY HEALTHY.
TRY TO HELP AND PAY BACK HOW
LUCKY WE'VE BEEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BRING PEACE TO THE WORLD.
I SEE SO MANY THINGS NOW THAT IS
TOO MANY, I HOPE PEOPLE CAN TALK
AND GET THINGS DONE IN A WAY AND
ONE OF MY DREAMS I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE A CUBAN VENEZUELA FREE AND
NICARAGUA, THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
A ROUGH TIME.
I HOPE THEY CAN ACHIEVE FREEDOM
AND CHOOSE THEIR OWN PRESIDENT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH
WHAT I WENT THANK YOU.
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH SO I CAN'T ASK FOR MORE.
WE'VE BEEN MORE THAN BLESSED.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN A
BLESSING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
>> I'M SORRY, I DON'T SPEAK
VENEZUELA.
[ SPEAKING LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH ]
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
>> SHE ASKED ME ABOUT VENEZUELA.
SOME AWARD PEOPLE SHOULD
NEVER -- SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOULD FEEL BECAUSE THEY WENT TO
CUBA AND VENEZUELA IS FAITH.
NOW WE LIVE IN A MOMENT THAT WE
HAVE INTERNET, WE HAVE PHONES
THAT RECORD.
PLEASE KEEP POSTING THINGS.
THEY'RE GETTING SUPPORT FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD BUT IT HAD TO
HAPPEN WITH THE VENEZUELAN
PEOPLE TO BE SURE THE WORLD KNOW
THEY WANT FREEDOM.
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> AND WE'RE SQUINTING A LITTLE
BIT --
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
>> CARMEN MIRANDA IN THE FIFTHS
50s.
RICKY RICARDO IN THE 50s AND
60s AND SANTANA IN THE 70s.
AND SUDDENLY, IN THE MIDDLE
80s, YOU CHANGE THE LATIN
MUSIC HISTORY FOREVER.
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
I'M FROM BOLIVIA.
I LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY 22 YEARS.
I DIDN'T GO TO SCHOOL TO LEARN
TO SPEAK ENGLISH.
I LEARN ON MY OWN BECAUSE I LOVE
MUSIC AND I USED TO REPEAT AND
REPEAT.
NOW I'M TEACHING BASIC ENGLISH.
YOU KNOW?
[ APPLAUSE ]
22 YEARS LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY
AND MAYBE I'M GOING TO LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY, MAY COUNTRY,
UNITED STATES.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY AND YOU
REALLY, REALLY INSPIRE ME.
I LOVE MUSIC LIKE NO ONE ELSE,
AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MY
COMMUNITY -- MORE THAN 20
COUNTRIES IDENTIFY TOGETHER
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING THROUGH
REALLY HARD TIMES.
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
I CAN COME BACK TO MY COUNTRY.
THIS IS MY COUNTRY, AFTER 22
YEARS.
I WOULD LIKE SOME WORDS BECAUSE
MAYBE, MAYBE, AND I SAY THIS
FROM MY HEART, MAYBE I'M GOING
TO LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
I LIVE IN MY OWN.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO HOW THE
MUSIC CAN PUT US TOGETHER AND BE
A REAL LATINO COMMUNITY.
PLEASE CAN YOU SAY SOMETHING?
>> I'M GOING TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING, WE ARE BLESSED THAT
EVEN WE WERE BORN IN CUBA WE
BELONG TO ALL OF YOU.
WE FELT ME AND GLORIA WE BROUGHT
A LOT OF LATIN AMERICA AND SOUTH
AMERICA TO US BECAUSE THEY
SUPPORT US IN THE BEGINNING.
EVERYBODY COMES SOMETIMES, IT'S
HARD, BECAUSE YOU COME WITH LIMP
LANGUAGES AND YOU COME WITH
DIFFERENT CULTURE.
I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW THIS
COUNTRY IS THE BEST COUNTRY IN
THE WHOLE WORLD AND THEY OPEN
DOORS AND THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO BE CUBAN
AMERICAN.
WE'RE BLESSED TO LIVE IN A FREE
COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO WORK HARD AND WE NEED
THE COMMUNITY TO GET TOGETHER TO
DO GREAT THINGS.
I'M VERY PROUD OF YOU.
VERY PROUD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I'M SHAKING.
>> HE SAID I'M SHAKE.
YOU'RE PROBABLY THE ONLY ONE.
I'M IN THE AIRPLANE, AND WE'RE
IN KENNEDY AIRPORT.
GLORIA IS PLAYING WITH TWO DOGS.
EVERYBODY WHO PASSES BY EMILIO,
TAKE A PICTURES.
THE CAPTAIN SAYS NO MORE
PICTURES BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
LEAVE.
YOU'RE AT KENNEDY AIRPORT YOU
HAVE TO LEAVE.
THE LAST PEOPLE THAT THEY WANT
TO TAKE A PICTURE IS A GUY WITH
TWO KIDS AND THE MOM.
SO THE MOM SAY, I TAKE THE
PICTURE.
THE GUY TAKES THE PICTURE.
I TAKE THE PICTURE AND THE KID
GOES NEXT TO ME LIKE THIS, AND
SAY:  WHO ARE YOU?
I TOLD HIM, RICKY MARTIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BUYING
THAT ALBUM.
I LOVE THAT.
ALL THE WAY FROM THE BEGINNING.
>> CONGA.
THERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
>> HI, GOOD EVENING: MAY
QUESTION IS.
ALL THE SPANISH IMMIGRANTS WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH A LOT THESE PAST
TWO YEARS.
FIRST WE WERE CALLED RAPISTS, WE
DON'T BELONG TO THIS COUNTRY.
WE'RE NOT A GOOD PEOPLE.
THEN THE SEPARATION OF THE
FAMILIES.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
THIS CONTROVERSY OVER THE WALL?
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- I'M
SORRY, IT'S A LITTLE BIT HARD
BUT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION?
LISTEN, I GONNA TELL YOU
SOMETHING THAT ALWAYS MEETING --
I'VE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH THAT I
PRODUCE FIVE DIFFERENT
ADMINISTRATIONS, DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICAN.
EVERY PRESIDENT HAS GOOD THINGS
AND BAD THINGS.
I THINK IMMIGRATION SHOULD BE
LEGAL BECAUSE WE GO THROUGH A
LOT OF ROUGH TIMES AND EVERY
COUNTRY SHOULD HAVE LEGALIZED
IMMIGRATION.
LIKE YOU SAY, I PLAN THINGS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I MEAN,
LIKE HE SAID, SOMETIMES PEOPLE
DON'T REALIZE THAT SOMETIMES
PEOPLE DON'T COME TO THIS
COUNTRY NOT ONLY LOOKING FOR A
BETTER LIFE, THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
FREEDOM TO SAVE THEIR FAMILY.
WHEN YOU HAVE A FAMILY, YOU WILL
DO ANYTHING THAT YOU HAVE TO DO
TO SAVE THEM.
TO BE SURE THAT YOUR KID WILL BE
ABLE TO LIVE IN A FREE WORLD,
AND I HOPE WE GET ORGANIZED IN A
WAY.
LISTEN, I WAS SHOWING HER A
PICTURE OF EVERY SINGLE
PRESIDENT TALKING TO THEM HOW WE
CAN GET MAYBE VISAS TO SEE ONE
THING THAT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, A LOT OF LATINOS WE
MADE A GREAT CONTRIBUTION TO
THIS COUNTRY AND WE LOVE THIS
COUNTRY.
A LOT OF LATINOS GO TO AER TO
THIS COUNTRY, LIKE GLORIA'S
FATHER HE COME BACK IN A
WHEELCHAIR.
A LOT OF LATINOS PAY TAXES TO
THIS COUNTRY.
WE'RE PROUD TO BE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
I HOPE THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
FIX ALL THIS PROBLEM WITH
IMMIGRATION TO BE SURE
LEGALIZING AND PEOPLE CAN COME
LEGAL WITHOUT HAVING ANY KIND OF
PEOPLE COMING ILLEGAL BECAUSE
PEOPLE GO THROUGH LOT OF ROUGH
TIMES WHEN THEY COME ILLEGAL AND
I THINK IT SHOULD BE ORGANIZED.
LIKE I SAY I HAVE FAITH IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I KNOW WE HAVE GREAT
PEOPLE AND IT'S GOOD WE HAVE A
SENATE THAT CAN MAKE DECISIONS
AND I HOPE THE PRESIDENT LISTENS
TO AND SEES HOW MUCH
CONTRIBUTION THE LATINO PEOPLE
MAKE FROM DIFFERENT COUNTRIES OF
THE WORLD LIKE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY.
SEE HOW MUCH THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY HAS DOWN DONE FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND THE ITALIAN
COMMUNITY.
THEY'VE COME TO THIS COUNTRY
ORGANIZED AND DOING A LOT OF
THINGS.
I HOPE THEY UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
THE SAME MESSAGE FOR THEM AND WE
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
>> MAY NAME IS CATHERINE.
I'M A MIGRANT FROM PERU.
I CAME TO THE UNITED STATES IN
THE YEAR 2000.
I GREW UP IN MIAMI.
VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE.
YOU'RE DEFINITELY A PART OF
MIAMI.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU WOULD BE:
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR ADVICE FOR
YOUNG MIGRANTS WHO HAVE NOW
BECOME A PART OF THIS COUNTRY
WHO PROBABLY SEE THEMSELVES LIKE
YOURSELF AS BICULTURAL,
BILINGUAL?
AND STILL MAKING AN ATTEMPT TO
REMAIN TRUE TO THEIR ROOTS IN
AREAS OF THE COUNTRY WHERE THEY
MIGHT INDEED BE VERY MUCH A
MINORITY?
>> WELL, LISTEN, WE HAVE --
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND LIKE I
SAID IN MUSIC WE HAVE SO MUCH
DIVERSITY.
WHEN PEOPLE COME FROM DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES, BE WHO YOU ARE.
I GOT LUCKY TO WORK WITH ONE OF
THE BEST MUSICIANS I WORK WITH,
MARCO.
MARCO CAME TO MIAMI TO ASK ME TO
HELP AND HE BECAME A GRAMMY
WINNER, PRODUCER AND WRITER.
HE'S GOING TO BE IN OUR SHOW.
THE REASON I WANT HIM TO BE IN
OUR SHOW BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES HAVING A STORY LIKE ME
AND GLORIA, THE STORY ABOUT
RICKY MARTIN AND SHAKIRA AND
YOUNG MARCO IS FROM PERU.
MAKES ME HAPPY THEY BECAME
SUCCESSFUL.
BE WHO YOU ARE.
DON'T TRY TO MAKE SUSHI.
TRY TO MAKE PERUVIAN FOOD.
WE HAVE RESTAURANTS THAT
SOMETIMES I SAY WHY DO YOU
MAKE -- I SAY WE'RE CUBAN.
HAS TO BE RICE AND BEANS.
THAT'S WHO WE ARE AND I THINK
WE'RE LUCKY WITH THAT.
>> WE HAVE TIME FOR JUST A
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS.
>> YOU KNOW HOW I FEEL?
I FEEL LIKE I DO THE WHOLE THING
ON TV WHEN THEY'RE RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I NEVER WANT TO GET INTO
POLITICS.
>> THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
OUR LAST QUESTION RIGHT OVER
HERE.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> RIGHT IN HERE.
>> EMILIO --
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
I'M GOING TO TRY TO BE VERY
BRIEF.
[ SPEAKING SPANISH ]
I'LL JUST SAY IT IN ENGLISH FOR
EVERYONE.
AS LATIN AND KNOWING HOW HARD
PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND US HERE AND
BEYOND, THEY WORK FOR THE
AMERICAN DREAM AND THEN LIVING
IN MIAMI, KNOWING ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THE ENVIRONMENT, MY
HARDEST PART AS AN ACTIVIST FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL MOVEMENT IS
HOW TO TELL MY PEOPLE TO NOT --
TO LOOK FOR A SMILE AND TRY TO
LIVE GREEN WHEN THEY ALWAYS
THOUGHT THE AMERICAN DREAM WOULD
BE HERE AND MORE.
SO RECONCILING THOSE HAS BEEN
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU COULD SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT OR PUT
IT IN YOUR HEART AND YOUR MIND
TRYING TO CREATE SOME MUSIC TO
SPEAK TO THE ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS
OF OUR ERA RIGHT NOW.
>> LISTEN, THE ENVIRONMENT, YOU
HAVE TO KNOW THAT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, WE HAVE TO MOVE INTO
THAT.
WE NEED TO MOVE AND PUT SOME
MONEY, WE NEED TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO THAT.
OTHERWISE THE NEXT GENERATION
WILL PAY A BIG PRICE AND THE WAY
TO DO IT IS CREATE
CONSCIOUSNESS, AND SHOW PEOPLE
HOW IF WE DON'T PAY ATTENTION,
HOW DIFFICULT IT'S GOING TO BE.
AS A LATINA LIVING IN MIAMI AND
NO MONEY, FOR ME IT WAS SO HARD
BECAUSE I WISH I COULD HAVE
STUDIED.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY.
OR LEARN MUSIC, OF BRINGING MY
MOM FROM CUBA THAT I SPENT 11
YEARS WITHOUT SEEING HER AND
BRING MAY BROTHER SO YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A BALANCE.
WE USED TO BE, MY 14 KIDS WITH
MY GRANDMOTHER SLEEPING IN A
ROOM AND I'M NOT ASHAMED TO SAY
THAT.
I'M ASHAMED I PLAYED THE
ACCORDION FOR TIPS IN AN ITALIAN
RESTAURANT THAT DIDN'T FEED ME.
I USED TO GET $5 AND BUY A
SANDWICH.
I THINK THAT TEACHES ME TO BE
REAL AND TO APPRECIATE LIFE, AND
TO GIVE HOPE TO SOMEBODY WHO
APPRECIATE AND BOUGHT A RECORD
FROM ME 30 YEARS AGO, I NEVER
WANT TO LOSE THAT.
BUT LISTEN, YOU HAVE TO BE
PERSISTENT.
PERSISTENT AND YOU HAVE TO PLAN
THINGS.
THE BEST WAY THAT I WILL SAY WE
CAN SHOW THE WORLD LATINOS AND
IMMIGRANTS AND NOT ONLY LATINOS
IS GIVING BACK.
GIVING BACK.
EVERY TIME WE RECEIVE AN AWARD
LIKE THE MEDAL OF FREEDOM OR THE
WEB GIN AWARD WHICH I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, IT'S NOT
ABOUT GETTING THAT AWARD FOR ME
AND GLORIA, IT'S ABOUT GETTING
THAT AWARD FOR MANY PEOPLE.
MANY PEOPLE GET INSPIRED THAT WE
DID IT THEY CAN DO IT.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT IT WAS TO
GO TO SLEEP WITHOUT EATING.
HOW DIFFICULT THE IT WAS NOT
BEING ABLE TO GO TO A MOVIE
THEATER, TO SAVE THE $3 TO BRING
MY MOM FROM CUBA.
LIFE WAS GOOD TO US.
WE ALWAYS WANT TO BE GOOD TO
LIFE.
AND WE ALWAYS I HOPE ME AND
GLORIA WILL BE A ROLE MODEL TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND TO SAY I ALWAYS SAID THAT
YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
THAT WE LIVE IN THE BEST COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD.
I ALWAYS SOMETIMES WHEN I DO
THESE THINGS AND EVERY NIGHT I
SAY GOD BLESS AMERICA.
WE LIVE IN A BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY.
I'M NEVER GOING TO LOSE PEOPLE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY, I CAN
TELL YOU THAT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> I MUST TELL YOU, WELL, IT'S
NOT -- YOU KNOW HOW THEY SAY
SOMETIMES THE MOVIE IS AS GOOD
AS THE BOOK, YOU ARE BETTER THAN
THE BOOK.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> OH MY GOD, I'M GOING TO DO A
COMMERCIAL.
>> THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR INSPIREING SO MANY
PEOPLE.
>> I WANT A HUG.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS.
>> I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
LET'S TAKE A PICTURE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.